[Music]
star butterfly has had a lot of
adventures for a teenager have you ever
wondered what she and the rest of the
gang would look like in 10 years stay
tuned to see our favorite fan art of the
star versus the forces of evil
characters all grown up no matter what
dimension you're from you'll love all of
our awesome videos click subscribe for
more content
now let's get to the best fan art of the
grown up star vs. the forces of evil
crew wow he is adorable glowed up Marco
the Marco we know in love from star
versus the forces of evil is kind of a
scrawny teenage kid but it's easy to
imagine that all the adventures he gets
into would get him in some serious shape
stars best friend always aspires to be a
misunderstood bad boy even though he's
so not but he sure has that vibe down in
his fan art artists silver 31 star from
deviantART has drawn an adult Marco who
is looking all sorts of cool this Marco
looks like he grew out of all his
self-esteem issues
check out that tattoo on his arm we
loved this depiction of Marco
Valentine's Day the couples and star
versus the forces of evil are total
relationship goals and we just want them
to last forever check out this piece
called celebrating Valentine's Day from
deviant artist Anna the cherry she has
drawn both star and Tom and Jackie Lynn
and Marco each grown up couple is
embracing with a kiss we just love this
sweet drawing star is a queen in this
place and her hair is on point Tom just
looks so in love with her adult Marco is
rocking a red tie with his black shirt
doesn't he look sharp the artist totally
captured Jacqueline's love for Marco in
this drawing we are so cute together
underworld romance the demon Prince in
the underworld has stolen our hearts and
stars perfect princess girl on
deviantART is a huge shipper of tom and
star and we can't blame her in this
drawing we don't know exactly how old
tom and star are supposed to be but they
are definitely looking much cooler and
more mature puberty we
lewberty and apparently very kinds of
demons Tom lucid er looks like a
punk-rock dream we love how the artist
managed to capture their real looks
while making them grow up some and we
can't get enough of Tom trying to be
romantic with that fiery rose it's a
match made in heaven
well not heaven but that other place
trendy star Farah princess from another
dimension
star butterfly is usually a pretty
stylish teenage girl but would she stick
with the same outfits as a young adult
or would she go with something a bit
more mature we found this awesome
drawing of star as a young adult on
deviantART artist Marcos power 1996 has
updated her outfit to something a bit
trendier she's still wearing her
quintessentially star colors it would be
totally weird if she wasn't wearing
shades of teal and purple but she's got
a cute multicolored dress on this is a
great look for an older star don't you
think
adult Jackie Lynn who we love Jackie
Lynn Thomas she is such a great
character and we were really sad when
she broke things off with Marco even
though interdimensional adventures would
take a toll on any relationship right
and Jackie Lynn is always on point with
her streak of aqua hair and laid-back
athletic clothes anna HSS from
deviantART kept her adult version of
Jackie Lynn with the same easy cool vibe
she still got the same hair and
knee-high socks but she has traded in
her Ragland shirt for a regular green
t-shirt and a brown sweater she looks
amazing
do you think an older Jackie Lynn would
keep the same style as her teen self
remember I'm not the only one with horns
the men of star versus the forces of
evil
we just love a drawing with a bunch of
our favorite characters
thanks to Loretta one two three on
deviantART
we can see that all the boys of star
versus the forces of evil will look like
as men Marco has the same chill hoodie
loving style with a 5 o'clock shadow on
his face tom has filled out and added a
trench coat to his look Ferguson has
slimmed up and is hopefully less awkward
with the ladies now that he's all grown
up
Oscar is still playing guitar but looks
way more mature who is that character in
the end that is the original character
created by the artist to be a girlfriend
for Jackie Lynn this is one seriously
talented fan artist stars friends
Loretta one two three showed us what all
the guys will look like grown up but we
also found a drawing of all of stars
girlfriends on the artist deviantART
page she did a great job star fan 13 has
certainly grown out of her awkward stage
do you think she stays obsessed with
star she looks super cute in this
drawing
Janice still manages to keep a dark
style while trading in her beanie and
skirt for a new outfit and we just love
Jackie Lynn with long hair and a beach
boho vibe it's perfect okay we know
Britney isn't exactly stars friends but
it looks like grown-up Britney is still
kind of a grump she's traded in her
cheerleading outfit for a fancy cocktail
dress that seems fitting for her gender
benchmark Oh fan art is so amazing we
can see our favorite characters drawn as
kids or adults and we can get some
amazing gender bends deviantART Leo the
Pug art - stuff decided to illustrate
not just a grown-up Marco but a gender
bent Marco - so here is what Marco would
look like as an adult woman this sketch
is so awesome
Marco looks ready for battle the hair is
pretty much the same while being more
feminine you can really see the
inspiration for Marco in this what an
amazing piece Marco x Tom there are some
great ships in the star vs. the forces
of evil universe and one popular ship is
Marco Diaz
and Tom lucid ER in this cartoon from
deviantART Zinka 17 through adult
versions of Marco and Tom Marco has
seriously buffed up and is showing off
his six-pack Tom seems to have realized
he has a crush on Marco he's left
totally speechless Tom doesn't seem to
have matured as much as Marco but we
don't really know what happens to demons
as they get older anyway our Marco and
Tom your OTP we could totally get behind
this pairing thanks Marco
family portrait at some point star
butterfly will grow up and become Queen
if she marries Tom a prince it will be a
perfect match
deviant artist and of the Cherry
imagined what their family portrait will
look like she even created an original
character for their daughter star looks
amazing as Queen in this teal dress and
a king outfit is a great look for Tom
don't you think their daughter has bats
on her cheeks representing influences
from both of her parents we bet Tom and
Starr are great parents who is your
favorite star versus the forces of evil
character let us know in the comments
and that's a wrap on the characters of
star versus the forces of evil
ten years later check out our community
page and click subscribe for more
awesome content
[Music]